com pesquisadores da cultura da mistura
e como criativa criar projetos a partir
desse tema sempre foi a minha grande
paixão
na verdade não é nem uma grande paixão e
depois que a gente entra numa idade de
30 anos e começa aquela coisa de retorno
de saturno
descobri que isso é muito a minha missão
e por que essa missão eu sou filha de um
palestino com uma brasileira que é filho
de uma índia com o português e eu fui
criada dentro de uma loja popular
aquelas barato barato o patrol que seu
passo aqui eu não sei que a princípio
pensava que eu aprendi na loja fazer
isso meu primeiro emprego e aí foi
dentro dessa loja que assim que não há
quem não é daqui vai saber que é igual
sarah que é igual a 25 de março e vai
todos os lugares do centro do país foi
dentro dessa loja que é mais ou menos 20
anos atrás eu descobri que nascer nesse
país é e com aquela mistura toda aquela
loja aquela gente aquela que o camelô
gritava pacoteiros coisa toda que a cada
dia fica mais feliz com aquilo eu
descobri que nascer aqui no brasil faria
com que eu conseguisse ou pudesse criar
uma estratégia pra a não casar mais com
um primo que era prometida enfim porque
eu era filho de árabe palestino criado
aqui mas que tenha como tinha cultura
mesmo no brasil um dia ter casamentos ou
pelo menos ter que casar com um outro
árabe
e aí também foi a partir desse momento
eu pensei que eu poderia ser uma mulher
livre então disse
nossa esse é o país né eu quero aqui eu
tenho que criar como que eu vou fazer
plantão
enfim poder colocar minha voz e como
mulher expressar o que pensa e não só a
cera mãe apesar de a massa marie mas mãe
e mulher esposa beleza
aí eu adoro lembrar
um pouco quando se fala de brasil porque
tem uma frase muito bem disse carol pra
mim hoje em dia tem sido a minha grande
poeta e ela fala coisas eu gosto muito
dessa lei de gravar nada contra ti não
me leve a mal quem descobriu o brasil
não foi o cabral porque eu fico pensando
que apesar de o jogo ser feliz ao lado
quando tinha 12 anos de idade descobri
que nasci aqui seria muito bom pra mim
eu noto que as pessoas hassan
nesses lugares a cidade desse país não
se sentir representados ou não se sentiu
muito feliz
até quando conversávamos e pesquisadora
porque já conversei com muita gente
viaja o brasil inteiro conversando
fazendo campo com mulheres jovens
pessoas de todas as idades mas até mesmo
dentro da loja eu vi que as pessoas não
sentirem representadas não é assim é
legal brasileiro de nossa você tá muito
sorte foi livre né
não seria eu tô não tinha essa coisa de
dizer não se sentir talvez tão
representada como até recomendável
contando que a maioria das porque de
novo a maioria das referências vão
receber não representam o brasil urgente
brasil é enorme o território brasileiro
é um absurdo eu me lembro quando comecei
a fazer campo como você viajar quando
saí do rio grande do sul começa a andar
disse meu deus que coisa linda cada dia
me apaixonava mas perceba brasil quanto
no pará quando vai abrir dez pontos no
rio de janeiro e cada história daria mil
na ativa flexa
então isso não é colocado não é mostrado
e é muito estranho muito triste a gente
não ver isso né
porque é que tudo que a gente absorve
são referências de fora
eu normalmente que trabalha como pessoa
que trabalha muito também com tendências
tudo que a gente tem que olhar é para
fora
a gente sempre olha referências nórdicas
o que vem de cima e que não sabia onde
sabe ninguém gosta de se reconhecer até
quando a gente viaja a gente quer viajar
para fora do país não quer viajar pra
dentro
então tem essa questão toda de não ser
representado mas a gente também não têm
essa cor é essa esse grande amor de
conhecer o outro conhecer o próprio
território
muitas vezes eu vejo aqui uma
representação de um pouco de mim que eu
não vejo nesses lugares mas que também
tem várias outras histórias de pessoas
nordeste de pessoas do interior
contar uma história aqui da pró cultura
lazer o a galera lado do interior e
ganso não sabe quanto que não aparece
coisa muitas vezes gaúcha ea gente sabe
o eixo rio são paulo
então eu vi ninguém muito representado e
aí a partir disso na minha vida comecei
a sentir essa missão de criar também
projetos não só pesquisar mas criar
projetos último projeto que eu fiz se
chama sou dessas né o nome que foi muito
pra passar o microfone para mulheres que
eu admirava e que essas mulheres
pudessem contar suas histórias seus
movimentos entre elas chamavam sou
dessas e principalmente mulheres que
além de ter os seus trabalhos elas
também eram são articuladores de redes
são pessoas que misturam assim como as
meninas aqui no ted também são
articuladores são pessoas que estão
fazendo a gente agora ouvir essas
histórias ea gente se misturar
não sou dessas a gente usou o palco ou
pra falar de um movimento muito grande
que a gente começou a identificar entre
as mulheres que por exemplo as e
virologia quando um dos meninos estava
contando sobre a mãe
eu fiquei pensando muito na hora as mães
do brasil são as verdadeiras servirá
longas assim dependente porque sempre
trabalham pra fazer várias coisas e elas
têm que fazer um corre ainda mais quando
não é independente de classe mas quando
a gente abre periferias fazem dez vezes
mais ocorre não tem muita gente para
ajudar tem sim os vizinhos porque a
economia colaborativa dentro de
comunidades é maior até do que fora dela
mas enfim então nesse dia a gente
começou a discutir e dizer porque vamos
trazer a mulheres servir ólogos e
fazedores para contar suas histórias e
compartilhando que quer ser o logia né
gente
muitas vezes fala galera fala que é
muito há como dizer o reinaldo pamponet
trouxe muito essa primeira essa esse
termo mas aqui com a gente ouve sobre
fedor gente ouve muito como a gambiarra
o jeitinho brasileiro até o nosso jeito
de criar nossa criatividade nosso jeito
difícil de se virar
muitas vezes ele é diminuído e não é
visto como a criatividade inovadora
tecnologia fosse visto pelos caras de
tendências faria seria visto como meia
ou a cultura maker o elysée nossa os
hackers né então e quando a gente ouve
falar sobre maker sobre cultura hacker
parece que a gente está falando sobre
inovadores que vieram de outros lugares
dentro das universidades como outra sair
por aí é que são enfim estados unidos
conhecida por tecnologia e tudo mais mas
quando a gente traz e se reconhece como
não eu sou um meia que eu sou uma
fazedora eu sou um ser logo começa a
entender que aquilo faz parte que eu sou
uma pessoa criativa que eu posso fazer
acontecer e isso não é diminuído então
imagina a nossa as nossas referências
elas são até diminuídos e colocadas como
jeitinho brasileiro gambiarras dizer uma
grande força criativa uma grande jeito
de trabalhar e criar dentro de pequenas
barreiras esse é um exemplo de
tecnologia mas a própria o carnaval
junto com a galera cria olha o tamanho
do carnaval gente pelo amor de deus é
muito difícil fazer tudo aquilo e aquilo
tudo isso acontece por um trabalho
coletivo muito bem colocado e por vários
e ver os jogos
então a gente identificou diversos e
drogas aqui a yasmim foi uma das nossas
convidadas até contar a história
mas mais importante dentro desse projeto
foi ela tem um pouco da a gente tem que
ter o tempo todo na nossa cabeça mas a
gente pode ter consciência são
consciência são consciência ao saber que
existe alguma algumas coisas e trazer as
referências mas criar e fazer algo é
muito mais importante ea gente tem que
sentir todos não culpados mas sentir sim
a gente nesse momento então aqui a gente
traça também um dado muito forte que é a
bola um pouco sobre a servir o longa que
hoje 40% das casas são comandadas por
mulheres
se a gente vai pra outros lugares como
comunidade a gente vê que 70% é
comandado pelas mesmas nem as mulheres
sintam representados assim na política e
também na mídia
as mulheres hoje elas estão também a
gente fala servir aos fazedores elas
também dão cada vez mais sendo as
propagadoras de um novo mas cede
sociedade novo pensamento é cada vez
mais a gente vê e eu fico muito feliz
como
é vendo mulheres fazedores brasileiras
também sendo propagadoras sendo um spa
fone eu vejo que a partir da nossa
tecnologia de ter as redes sociais agora
como mídia as pessoas têm voz
a gente vê que alguns movimentos eles
começam a emergir de vários lugares mas
é muito interessante ver que essa mulher
vereadora também está fazendo isso pra
mudar muito a realidade o que a gente
pode aprender com essa energia nef
menina eu mesmo quando eu tive que fazer
a mesma estratégia pra não ficar lá com
meu primo e tal ea gente como mulher a
gente está muito acostumada a servir a
gente foi muito oprimida e sendo sempre
sendo aquela pessoa como eu tenho que me
importar para servir a alguém como eu
tem que importar para ser aceita pelo
homem não vai me dizer sempre assim não
sabe cozinhar não vai casar
hoje a média de dezembro estava cantando
com 18 anos ninguém vai querer dizer a
gente eu quero fazer faculdade ao marido
vai deixar fazer faculdade e eu dizia
meu deus como é que eu vou com toda essa
história aí eu descobri lá e meu pai não
gostava de um certo biotipo que meu pelo
meu primo tinha esse certo o biotipo eu
falei pai olha só
por favor vamos fazer assim escolhi o
outro namorado mas se ele é a verdade
então olha vou escolher um filho de um
brasileiro moderno pra você casar e aí
eu consegui em rolar
mas isso tudo é dizer que essa esse
jeito da mulher também ser meio não é
manipuladora mas vamos dizer que ela tem
uma certa articulação de entender muitas
vezes por ter sido reprimido até ficar
em prestar muita atenção
ela tem uma sensibilidade e talvez fazer
conexões em redes e de misturar porque
também é a mulher que gera um filho ela
que traz a vida a gente não vê que
muitas vezes eu falo que se as mães não
mudaram o mundo de quem vai mudar né
porque nada mais forte do qa a nossa
energia feminina
e uma coisa muito importante que a gente
tem que pensar quando ele pensa e
mistura e aí como tá falando antes de
empatia é o quanto a tecnologia sim veio
para nos ajudar a misturar mas o quanto
muitas vezes um facebook da vida é não é
a realidade não é a nossa realidade é um
algoritmo e facebook não sei se todos
estão familiarizados ele muitas vezes
mostra para ti só o que você gosta então
quanto mais da lic nos assuntos das
pessoas
ele começa a criar um algoritmo produção
receber aquilo que isso não é uma
realidade e isso é muito perigoso porque
isso é esse momento que está vivendo no
brasil é o momento de polarização
muitas vezes acontece porque as pessoas
têm poder de determinados
é pensamento que eu acho que todo mundo
pensando como ela e ela começa e é muito
agressivo enquanto aquilo aquilo tá
muito é refletido talvez uma um olhar
que ela tá olhando só para o seu umbigo
literalmente ou para sua timeline e ela
acha que é realidade e aquilo não é
realidade
então na verdade a mistura não vai
acontecer na frente do facebook não vai
acontecer se a gente não se movimentar
a mistura tem a ver com o movimento
então a primeira questão antes de
provocação contra água a gente enquanto
o povo brasileiro precisa sair do
armário sabe fazer uma espécie de
terapia coletivo porque a mudança na
verdade vem de dentro do
autoconhecimento de eu não ter vergonha
de dizer que os índios lá os índios que
estão lá há centenas deles não fazem
parte da minha vida há porque os negros
que estão morrendo não faz parte da
minha vida porque o destino dos
refugiados que estão vindo para o brasil
o iraniano as crianças que tamanho não
faz parte da minha vida porque o meu
território aqui ele está muito bem
guardado
só que a gente não é isso gente desculpa
gente brasileira brasileira monte de
mistura vai ficar cada vez mais
misturando não tem essa coisa de ser uma
rasa e é essa nossa grande riqueza
abundante
se a gente não tiver um autoconhecimento
e ver que isso é forte a gente não vai
assim poder enquanto o povo
a gente não se poderá quando o povo e
enquanto nação e muita gente de fora não
quer que a gente sem poder enquanto o
povo porque nosso território é muito
interessante é a gente vai deixar com
que essa inteligência coletiva se vá se
vá pela radicalização se vá pela briga e
se vá pela polarização a gente entender
que tendências elas estão do nosso lado
que é a coisa mais interessante que
acontece pode ser uma ideia que nem em
off flip que pode ser que nem uma poeta
porque eu acho e ficaram ou forma de se
vestir de pessoas que estão trazendo um
estilo próprio de se vestir e não pra
fora olha tudo que o brasil tem mais
chance só trabalhava no brasil assim
enquanto interessante a gente teria de
idéias e de inovação como dizem que há
na verdade todos os criativos na área de
inovação independente os mais citados
por escolas é muito bem renomadas eles
falam é uma grande ideia nascer ela tem
que ter uma equipe heterogéneo né ele
tem que ter uma mistura entre essas
pessoas a gente tem tudo isso
então a primeira coisa é a que estou
provocando aqui porque essa venda de
ação não é muito de consciência e ação é
cada um aqui deve ser um viajante de
mistura e se não for não estou ganhando
acharmos culpados nem também nessa vibe
mas na verdade é tipo eu sim posso ser
um agente mistura eu médico e um
advogado eu criativa e pesquisadora eu
comunicador eu sempre quis semana uma
grande comunicador que existe aí popular
brasileira e designers conhecer a futura
fulana porquê porque eu queria misturar
o povo todo botar na televisão e trazer
as coisas que eram do brasil e
descobriram eu posso fazer isso então
porque comecei a fazer como a gente
mistura primeiro reconhecer diferentes
referências para ter uma uma visão do
coletivo certo mas não preciso
reconhecer e andar
eu na verdade também preciso espalhar
isso eu tenho que ser um inseto tem que
ser as dicas do bem gente a gente tem
espírito agro fulano pegou pegou pegou
pico pegou pegou todo mundo pegou a
atriz misturada meu deus como é sentir
que ele foi como essa
futebol é isso entendeu essa é a vai ver
não é tipo não faz parte de mim eu quero
para miami não não entendeu
então aqui a idéia é que vocês saiam
daqui empoderadas eu sou um agente da
mistura
eu sou agente da mistura e o que é ser
um agente mirim é conectar redes e
principalmente falar com pessoas que
você não faria ou conectar pessoas que
não se falariam de forma exponencial o
espontâneo em mente a gente também não
pode negar bloquear aquele cara que a
gente razão revoltado ele tem que ouvir
o que eu estou falando no facebook ou eu
naquela na família família ótima família
um ótimo país tem aquela mesa da família
está lá há mas essa o aniversário da
morena minha filha a morena
olha que engraçado minha filha se chama
a morena eu sou tão misturado ela nasceu
loira de azul vai defender que a gente
também é e só aceito tudo é tudo
misturado
então na fama aniversário da morena eu
trouxe um ônibus de pessoas que encheram
em eu trouxe um monte de gente
quero meus amigos da família do meu
marido tinha gente evangélica e tinha
gente não evangélica e tinha gente
branca tinha de perder entrou um monte
de gay amigo meu de ser dono por puri
nado
nem eu me lembro que a galera assim toda
em volta da festa muita gente a oferta
gigante e todo mundo assim e eu toda
hora que o governo precisa assim mesmo
meio não né
feliz e eu olhei para o lado e falei
gente que bagunça isso aqui não precisa
é a apresentadora isso aqui é uma grande
mistura da lei foi muito engraçado de
batalha de rap mas também interdição e
foi isso foi lindo porque pessoas talvez
um evangelho que vai olhar um gay é uma
coisa meu deus e ficava olhando a
piscina assim meu amigo nada discreta
purina aqui é por ela
então essa era um pouco a história num
aniversário conseguir fazer isso a gente
pode fazer isso em qualquer lugar então
sem o agente de mistura é criar novas
narrativas trazer novas referência
dissemina histórias reais entender que a
gente colorido diversa e dessa
diversidade
as coisas ideias geniais e não se nos
respeitar enquanto o povo colorido a
nossa alegria nossa purpurina tem que
ser respeitado
a nossa verdadeira e riqueza nisso e não
ser revoltados não sempre brigões não é
nosso
nós estamos importando isso porque todos
nós na verdade somos coloridos e somos
purus na mistura gente ligada